la violencia en Colombia no cesa la
oficina de Naciones Unidas para los
Derechos Humanos reiteró su llamado para
acelerar el desmantelamiento de los
grupos armados del país el pedido se
enmarca en un informe que presenta
cifras desalentadoras sobre la violencia
en Colombia el año pasado
hemos visto el efecto de la violencia de
los grupos armados en los territorios y
por eso llamamos tanto a la política de
desmantelamiento porque son los grupos
armados no estatales y las
organizaciones criminales quienes están
generando tanta violencia en los
territorios las masacres en el país
aumentaron a 92 en 2022 En comparación
con las 78 2021 también en el año
anterior 116 líderes comunitarios y
activistas sociales fueron asesinados
con respecto a los 100 que murieron en
2021 hemos visto que en el 2022 siguen
habiendo altos niveles de masacres
homicidios de personas defensoras además
de la violencia cotidiana que sufren las
poblaciones y la del tejido social en
los territorios
2022 fue un año de transición en
Colombia la presidencia pasó de manos de
Iván Duque de tendencia derechista a las
de Gustavo Petro el primer mandatario de
izquierda del país un cambio en el poder
que también se reflejó en la concepción
de cómo contrarrestar la violencia Petro
ha impulsado como base de su programa
político la paz Total que busca abarcar
a los diferentes grupos armados del país
el gobierno ha reiniciado conversaciones
con el ejército de liberación nacional y
ha acordado el cese al fuego con bandas
criminales y dos facciones de las
disidencias de las FARC unos pasos que
siguen estando lejos de su meta de
ponerle Punto Final al conflicto de más
de 60 años en el que al menos 450,000
personas han perdido la